oh hey wait a minute wait what are you
doing what do you know anyway hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome alright welcome to my super
schoolhouse - come on in just click on
your name or you haven't been here
before just type it in and then click on
it it's that easy
uh-huh I didn't breathe that whole time
why is your mouth still flapping stop
flapping stop flapping
my name is mark-5
mark Kip Lee that's me welcome since
you're new be sure to check out the
controls yeah so this is baldies basics
plus now I don't know what's different
about baldies basics + versus baldies
basics in the original or even in the
anniversary update or in the various
other fan games that have been made but
apparently this one's different very
very different anyway oh let's what
hide-and-seek play hide and seek with
baldie can you beat all the levels
without losing explore ball these super
schoolhouse to your heart's content you
can explore any level you've reached in
hide and seek endless mode collect as
many notebooks as you can before Baldy
tags you both he speeds up over time at
notebooks slow him down try your hand at
one of all these crazy challenges or go
on a field trip whenever you want and
try to set the best course possible I'll
go high didn't
[Music]
elevate whose f1 okay cool thank you
hi Baldy
[Music]
okay all right okay
it's been a while since I've played
baldies so I honestly am unsure what to
do about anything here what we hiding in
here is this ooh
as it says ego I
well I mean what was that
that's the freakiest thing I've seen in
a long time
also hi ASMR cloud over here alright
sure
oh he heard that oh hey principal what
are you doing don't do it don't do it
don't do it don't do it yeah okay
so there's some okay don't understand
anything I'll do my an apple a day save
[ __ ] oh oh hey uh okay listen hide and
seek I don't appreciate it I don't like
it I like it none and I hate you hey boy
oh he got gummed stock gummed oh my god
he got gummed oh interesting okay oh
whoops
well that wasn't mother that wasn't the
ideal but okay alright so all I gotta do
is find all the notebooks then right oh
I was in here all these fog machine
malfunctioned again
[Music]
is that good is that bad
is that what one would call good or is
this what one would call bad who's there
is that gum man oh I'm Gumby bro
Oh shoes big hole big old boots I got
big boots oh oh there's not ideal all
right back into old baldies fashion it's
like I never left buddy hey you know why
not what's in here ah time I got all
these least-favorite tape and alarm
clock I don't know what these do but
they've got to help me some way all
right
no open up I didn't do them oh you I
thought that you were gonna give me a
little more I thought it was until I got
out but okay whatever
let's just get what we need and get what
we deserve I don't know what that is
dirty chalk eraser oh oh no no no why
this is this is not fair fix it so what
you would come to okay all right that's
No got it
he might have gotten gummed I bet he got
gummed I bet he got gum because he was
right behind me so he would have gotten
gummed right that's how that works
that's probably how that works so it's a
mixture of some more places to hide some
more things to get in terms of items oh
okay
I did the boots whatever that means
where is he
that's the question where is he oh he
must have seen me go in here
poof what o'clock
well I'm dead this is horrible
and there's the alarm clock so I've made
as much noise as possible inside this
one locker
he'll never know I'm here turns out that
didn't work
tubes oh no I'm running out of tubes
guys I'm running out of tubes
I'm almost tubed out that's fat again it
has been a while since I have played any
sort of baldies game and understanding
the mechanics by which things happen
here it more difficult than I was
remembering okay so he's gonna come this
way set an alarm clock there he'll never
know I don't know if that's doing
anything it's not doing anything maybe I
don't know so the trick is I just got to
figure out okay I don't want to watch
that thank you okay okay these two oh
wait no this is
this isn't what I wanted nope nope oh
god what have I done I was trying to do
something else that didn't work I was
trying to put the tape in the thing and
then it didn't go in the thing and then
I didn't wasn't able to get me no don't
gum me don't gum me a heads up no one's
here hey are you doing okay
I'm almost there I need one more at four
he shouldn't be that fast maybe oh not
my rump nah my rump again no that was
too close
oh no oh no wait problem problem problem
problem problem problem okay I think the
it's over here uh no here Oh where's
that I think in here I hope I just get
it and that I go do I gotta go to the
elevator if I do I'm in trouble oh no oh
oh no laughs not is the alarm
[Music]
try that again
do you really that was not my fault I'm
assuming you got to go back to the
elevator right that's probably what it
is okay the ass-slapping has not started
so I'm assuming everything's cool oh I
don't know what the hell you said you
know did you get Baldy did you get Baldy
I bet you got Baldy yeah I bet you got
fall do I look at her
there's my sneaking shoes stealthy do
whatever you're doing whatever you're
doing I hate it don't do anything that
you're doing outside hey speed boost
nope I'll admit it anyway
Oh what is this what is this what is the
the lockdown ow
sneaking shoes big butt oh I don't want
doob I need one more here oh so if I go
if I go here and then go here it should
get me towards the beginning I think yes
oh good oh no oh no do not sweep into me
oh hey oh oh
did I get YouTube points that what white
teeth keep me all right yeah I'm good
man I'm good
[Applause]
out of elevate I don't know you know it
takes a special kind of talent to make
stuff that looks this bad Wow
oh I didn't realize that was gonna start
the whole thing I wasn't quite ready for
it but okay sure why why am I run with
no run bar okay
hey sweeper all wait wait what why is
that
[Music]
burger burger this w Dino squeeze good I
need this to be able to get away that's
not good seven I got to find seven
notebooks that's a lot of notebooks no
no no no don't you sleep near me don't
you sweep to me is it like
randomly-generated
I'm starting to understand that maybe
that actually is how this is going
because if it is that's a problem oh
he's right there I'm gonna get this one
then I'm gonna go in this next one and
I'm gonna know squid so he has no idea
I'm here oh they're all in here
Oh hear that that's not right
don't oh hey oh well not really he's a
good thing when he can see me do not gum
me don't gum me I did it log log log
what a minion yeah I know right pretty
good you know I'm pretty good they all
call me pretty good mark I'm pretty good
at what I do pretty good pretty good and
wait wait wait wait wait wait don't die
don't die don't die why am I so slow why
am I so slow why am I so slow wait wait
no stop don't die
wait I'm very slow know where I was
almost there and you took my sticks how
could you do such a thing
oh no the fire oh wow yeah Wow okay cool
I'm gonna go get more stick okay so long
as mister dude don't come swinging
through the trees with a tree on his
head it should be okay
oh I'm slower because I'm laden heavy
and thick with stick I understand now I
am quite rotund with stick I okay what
was that I don't know you know what I'm
just gonna run out into the woods and
I'm gonna see what's over here because I
don't know it just says no why does it
say no I don't know why it says no I
don't understand it just says no it just
says no I guess it means don't go past
it
oh oh hey wait a minute wait what are
you doing what do you know a way no oh
[Applause]
all right you heard nothing
bull are you still in detention I'm
still titute ice-t-- oh my god I'm
drowning
oh all right just kill me then
[Music]
oh alright hey I am good you know let's
why not right we're gonna do this for
realsies this time apparently you were
cover stamina just walking around in the
grass which is cool good to know I'm
gonna keep that in mind and then die I
don't want to go anywhere near the
vacation bus there's no purpose to go in
the vacation bus so why would anyone
want to go there six wait six six I
guess why can't I walk out and I open
that door no wait no hang on
wait what we know stop I don't want to
die no I don't want I don't wanna die
alright thanks I got a finger let's do
this thing
Baldy [ __ ] hi bud ba bud okay so
apparently there's some weird-ass math
machine in here so I'm just gonna I'm
just gonna blast through this like it
was nothing - where's - there's - Wow
stay away from me you demon globe
[Music]
there is no need Oh
I literally can't leave until oh it was
a trick his trap I had trapped you
trapped me you trapped me made me think
that I okay and then okay and then I you
know I'm just gonna leave he's gonna
leave she's gonna leave
cuz that was horrible and why would I
stay in a place that was gonna treat me
poorly like that no crap okay he'll have
no idea I'm here he should have no idea
that I'm here right he should not
locker locker locker locker locker he'll
never know
he'll never know okay he knows hey man
this leak thank you hey sweeper man I
wonder if I just wait here long enough
is there a chance that he could be swept
away is there like a possibility there's
probably no possibility however at least
I won't die Baldy at least I won't die
so what's the point of the lockers then
if it's not to escape his wrath which it
seems like it is but it's also not
because he man he wants me all right
here we go
you'd also don't recover Sam in there no
hey I'm just fast enough
I'm just fast look I don't know how that
worked up but hey I'm alive and so long
as I don't get another notebook I'm good
baby I'm good I've got this I have this
in the bag in what bat my bag in my bag
I have this also if I walk around here
I'll recover my stamina nice oh wait
wait wait wait wait wait I didn't plan
this right I didn't plan it through it I
didn't plan it through I know I wanna go
to the principal's office
I really would rather not go to the
principal's office this is all the same
is this like a mandatory thing sounds
like a blast you know it sounds like a
real blast sounds like a real hoot and a
half but I'm gonna have to thank but I'm
gonna have to I'm gonna have to say Oh
No
why is it like this why is it like this
why is it oh no you know what screwed
I'm not I don't like you
yeah boohoo no why have you done this
why would you do this why would you do
this why would you do this to me why
would you do this no please Bowlby i
Baldy I've made no progress since last
we spoke
can I get this anymore I can't
oh hey boy sure is huh
no what are you doing stop it weirdo
okay real old strats but good stress
point hmm okay I've been through this
one okay gotta get through this one for
where's the fort for thank you I know
I'm amazing where ah of course zero four
zero zero zero zero zero yeah he's real
fast now that's the problem that's
problem this I don't know what that did
probably nothing
oh god I need like soda so bad oh no six
of seven he's gonna be so fast you'll
never know there's a cloud of joy the
cloud of talk did nothing
yeah you tell me
[Music]
all right cool yeah um hang on what are
these other things field trips dumb and
let's mode no thank you Explorer mode I
don't know why would I want to explore
challenges you've stuck in school after
hours Shirley principle of the things
will be after you use dirty chalk
erasers lockers and your map to avoid
being seen and collect seven notebooks
it's just you at baldi in this child's
the catches ball if you move super fast
can you think fast enough to collect 25
notebooks to skip the school grapple
your legs might use a grappling hook see
if you can outwit Baldy and his friends
when this is your only way to move oh
wow I just want to try the speedy ones
because I think that'll be ridiculous
here we go baby so fast oh my goodness
I'm so fast oh my god oh god I can't
even get to the door Oh 25 cents
required that's a weird door my ass will
not sustain that kind of damage Baldy oh
I'm out of run that's my problem
Oh No Baldy please
all right so if you want to see more
ball these basics plus let me know down
in the comments below thank you
everybody so much for watching check out
more of all these basics that I've done
down the description and the suggested
videos down there and as always I will
see you bye bye
[Music]